19:45 really represents the final throes
of World War two in Europe you might
remember at the end of 1944 we have the
Battle of the Bulge starting which is an
incredibly bloody battle the US forces
which kind of take the brunt on the
Allied side lose 20 roughly 20,000
troops but by January they're able to
break through and invade Germany so as
you go into early 1945 the Allies are in
their march through Western Germany now
if you go on the east the Russians or
the Soviets are also marching westward
and by and by January of 1945 they're
able to take Warsaw and from then from
there they continue to march masse
westward towards Berlin now the writing
is on the wall at this point the Allies
look like they are going to win and so
they meet at Yalta the major powers to
discuss well what happens to Europe
after World War two how what happens to
Germany's split up what influence will
the different allied victors have in the
different countries of World War two so
this is happening in Yalta in February
of 1945 so let me write that down that's
in February now all the while this is
happening even though the writing is on
the wall that the Allies are going to
win the war they weren't taking anything
for granted they wanted to absolutely
force a surrender by the Axis powers in
Germany in particular so they continued
to firebomb major cities of Germany and
firebombing is an incredibly devastating
form of bombing where you're literally
trying to destroy the city set the city
on fire and the most notable of these
fire the cities that were firebombed
were Hamburg and Dresden the firebombing
of Dresden movies and books are written
about it that the the Nazis did also
firebomb London but that didn't have
quite the same devastating effect as the
Allied fire bombing of Hamburg and
Dresden and actually of Tokyo and other
Japanese cities as we will see in a few
minutes but then everything really comes
to a head in April of 1945 it's in April
that as you can see as you get into
April in May the the Allies are able to
essentially occupy major chunks of
Germany they're able to push Axis forces
outside of Italy they have effectively
won Mussolini gets captured and then
gets executed soviets are able to take
berlin and maybe most importantly April
30th Hitler commits suicide so Hitler
commits suicide and he's not the only
one several other major leaders of Nazi
leaders commit suicide as we go into
this period right over here so
essentially the war is won in Europe at
this point and then that's made official
on may 8th May 8th which is a good day
to remember known as VE Day Victory in
Europe Victory in Europe day so the
Allies have won in Europe but everything
is not over yet
World War two is still going on in the
Pacific so let's go down to the Pacific
Theater so starting with the starting
the year in in January the Allies are
able to take the island of Luzon in
particular they're able to take Manila
then as we go as we go into February
they begin the invasion of Iwo Jima
which is an incredibly bloody campaign
you have 70,000 Marines
invade the island versus 22,000 Japanese
troops and on top of that you obviously
have air you have the air force involved
you have you have the the the Navy
involved but what I guess even more
mind-boggling you have significant
Allied debts you have 7,000 debts on the
Allied side but even more amazing out of
the 22,000 Japanese soldiers that were
defending Iwo Jima 19,000 get killed
so 19,000 of 22,000 Japanese soldiers
get killed so you can imagine how bloody
this is and this picture which is
probably one of the most famous military
photos ever taken especially United
States this was taken by this was taken
of Marines storming a hill touring a
mountain in Iwo Jima and just to imagine
how bloody these things are I just give
you some of the numbers even this photo
which is a real photograph even this
photo where it looks like hey look the
Americans have you know they've at least
taken this take
this this mountain or this hill right
over here even out of this photo three
of these Marines die in the next few
days as they continue to try to take Evo
Jima or take the entire island so you
can imagine there the Japanese are able
to mount a ferocious defense of the
island and that is they aren't able to
fully take the island until we get into
March so by March March so maybe I'll
say from February to March
you have the invasion of Iwo Jima now
the whole time that this is happening
you have b-29s firebombing major cities
in Japan and especially Tokyo so once
again these cities are really being
destroyed this is all-out war but still
the Japanese have not surrendered and so
in April April actually April going into
June and you have to remember April in
in Europe this is when you know it look
you know it was pretty much done with
Hitler commits suicide in April but in
April going into June of 1945 you have
the Allied invasion of Okinawa which
once again is incredibly is an
incredibly bloody campaign you have not
you know above and beyond the the tens
of thousands of Japanese soldiers that
kill get killed in Okinawa you have tens
and tens of thousands of civilians who
get killed or commit suicide so once
again this is all very unpleasant and
and very and very bloody but we continue
on and still the Japanese have not
surrendered although you know we've even
in 1944 their Navy is is all but
destroyed but they have they're mounting
this ferocious defense but then in
parallel to all of this the Allies have
especially the US has had the Manhattan
Project to develop nuclear weapons and
they decide to use them Truman is now
president in order to accelerate the end
of the war and so in so in August 6th
they drop an atomic bomb on Hiroshima
essentially destroying that city and
it's interesting to read accounts of
even how the Japanese learn
about it or what they didn't learn about
it obviously because now obviously no
one was expecting bombs that could just
obliterate a city literally in seconds
and so the still there wasn't a
surrender from the Japanese and so let
me write this this is August 6th and so
on August 9th you have another atomic
bomb dropped on Nagasaki and at the same
time that this is happening you have the
Soviet Union invading Manchuria you have
the Soviet Union invading Manchuria and
so enough was enough you have the
Soviets who are now getting involved in
the Pacific the the Americans seem to be
able to literally destroy Japanese
cities at will and so on August 14 1945
you have the you have the Japanese
surrender Japanese surrender and then
this does not become I guess truly
official until September 2nd 1945 which
is called VJ Day Victory in Japan day
and then that Mort marks the real end of
World War two obviously World War two
ended at the end of April May officially
early May in Europe but now in Sept
early September it is officially ended
in the Pacific as well and the Allies
are victorious